Once 3 minutes are over, then there will
be a bell ring.
So, that shows that your time is up. So,
the next participant coming, just make
sure that you try to conclude your
speech within 3 minutes.
Brother Ahmed Shafiq.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Bismillah
Bismillah.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Alhamdulilahi
Rabbil Alameen was salatu was salaam ala
Ashraful Ambiya wal Muslimeen wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajma'een.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.
Subhanallah this is
the second time being on the stage and
then the time given is to choose any
topic about Islam
uh
the topic that I have chosen for today
is
Who is Allah?
As we all know in today's world Allah
the word Allah
is known by
largely by Muslim and both not Muslim
and non-Muslim community. Allah is known
as the name of the God of the Muslims.
As for Muslims
Allah
the word Allah
is the name
of God of everything. Since the
beginning it was always Allah and it was
always be Allah.
So from the Muslim understanding
that the non-Muslim
at least
that Allah is a word to refer to God.
And it's not
God as in
because when you use God
every in history
every culture every language have their
own word
to say God.
In Malay it's called Tuhan.
Or in Sanskrit it's called Tuhan or in
Chinese
they have a different word Shanti Shanti
in in Japanese probably it's Kami.
And they have different languages to say
the word God and in English it's God as
in g o d.
But then today Muslims are
claiming that the only word
the only name of God that the the name
of God is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Is Allah.
Because
only God
can
tell you what is his name.
And for the Muslims we believe that the
Quran is the word of God and Allah says
in the Quran and God, that we believe
that that is God,
Or Allah says that
Allah introduces himself
in Surah Al-Ikhlas, chapter 112,
Qul Hu Allahu Say, he
is Allah, the uniquely one. Qul Hu
Allahu Ahad. Allahu Samad.
He's the eternal.
Lam Yalid wa lam Yulad.
He does not beget, nor nor he was
begotten.
Wa lam yakun lahu kufuwan ahad. And
there's nothing like him.
So, that is the criteria of
Allah, and also the criteria of God.
And
Allahu Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam Allahu
Akbar.
Speechless.
So, that uh that is
With that, I conclude my speech.
Assalamu Alaykum wa Rahmatullahi Alaykum
Assalam wa Rahmatullahi wa Barakatuh.
Brother Ibrahim Guthrie.
I'd like to welcome all of my brothers
in the audience, and viewers at home,
with beautiful greeting of Islam, the
greeting of peace,
the greeting of all of our beloved
prophets.
Assalamu Alaykum wa Rahmatullahi wa
Barakatuh. Alaykum Assalam wa
Rahmatullahi wa Barakatuh.
It's a very short amount of time to
speak,
but alhamdulillah, I want to touch upon
further what brother Kaleem said about
patience, about sabr.
Cuz during this training course, there's
going to be hardship, much hardship.
And we need patience.
Patience is mentioned in the Quran,
not in word, but in action, as well,
around between 90 to 100 times, plus.
On that, many times it's interlinked
with belief
or believers.
Bring it into being one of the
attributes of a believer.
Furthermore,
to have patience is to believe in the
unseen, to believe that Allah knows what
we don't know.
So, I want to touch upon the story of
Prophet Jonah,
may peace be upon him,
and the story of a whale.
So, during Dawah,
we're going to face situations where we
might go days, weeks, months, years
conveying a message, but no one
listening.
But, let us not make the same mistake as
Prophet Jonah made.
When people turned away, they rejected
him, they didn't listen to him his
beautiful message of Allah.
So, he got angry. He made a mistake. He
went away on the boat.
And subhanallah,
through a series of actions which you
can find in the noble Quran, final
message of Allah, of God, surah 10.
The whale swallowed Jonah.
Straight away, he knew what he'd done.
He knew that he had failed. He knew that
he had ignored message of Allah. He had
forgotten. He had ignored patience.
Furthermore,
when the whale took him and spat him out
on the beach after his Allah accepted
his dua,
he was wrapped in vines.
Furthermore, during dua, not screaming
despite being in agony and pain.
Once again,
demonstrating patience.
After this, he carried on his message of
Dawah and made his way round back to the
city where he came from or the town
where he came from.
And to that, he found his people,
the people praying to Allah, not
worshipping my idols, not forsaking
Allah.
So, through this,
he learned the message of patience
amongst other things.
So, I hope and pray that we can all keep
patience in our heart in this course,
and that Allah guides us to be patient,
in sha Allah.
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh. Wa alaykum as-salam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Dr. Farik Naik.
Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillah wa
ala alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in. Amma ba'd.
A'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani r-rajim.
Bismillahir rahmanir rahim.
Kullu nafsin dha'iqatul mawt.
Rabbishrah li sadri.
Wa yassir li amri.
Wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
My respected elders and my dear
brothers, I welcome all of you with
Islamic greetings. As-salamu alaykum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa alaykum
as-salam wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May the peace, mercy, and blessings of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala be upon all of
you.
The topic of my talk is
the destroyer of all pleasures,
death.
Let me share with you a shocking
incident that happened in Riyadh, Saudi
Arabia.
A construction worker
was working on the seventh floor of a
building
with no safety measures, and he suddenly
fell down.
But the shocking thing
that he survived and he had no injuries
whatsoever.
Everyone around him was amazed.
And this man, he jumped up with joy
having survived.
So he told everyone around him that he
would want to offer them some drinks in
celebration.
So he was crossing the road to get some
drinks.
And a car
banged him and killed him.
Imagine this man, he falls from the
seventh floor of a building
and he does not die.
Why? Because Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala had
not written his death.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala had appointed
for him the specific moment,
the exact second in which his soul would
be taken.
My brothers, death
comes unannounced.
Death approaches suddenly with no
appointments.
I started my talk with a quotation from
the glorious Quran from Surah Ali Imran,
chapter number three, verse number 185.
Kullu nafsin dha'iqatul maut. Every soul
shall have a taste of death.
Death
is a certainty that none can deny.
It is a reality,
but the important question is how much
are we prepared for it?
Ata bin Rabah, a famous tabi'i, he says,
"There There are three benefits of
remembering death.
The first is a person, he will hasten
towards repentance.
The second is a person, he will be He
will not fight
and compete over materialistic things.
And the third is
that he will be content with the bare
minimum in this obnoxious world of
materialism.
I would like to end my talk with the
Hadith
of the Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam in Sunan Ibn Majah, Hadith
number 4258.
An Abi Hurairah radi Allahu anhu qala,
qala Rasulullah Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam, "Akthiru dhikra hadhimil
ladhdhat, ya'ni al-mawt." The Prophet
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam said,
"Remember often the destroyer of all
pleasures," by which he meant death. Wa
akhiru da'wana alhamdulillah Rabbi
al-Alamin.
Brother Koichiro Sugimoto.
Bismillah Rahman Rahim.
Alhamdulillah Rabbi al-Alamin was-salatu
was-salam ala Sayyidina Muhammad wa ala
alihi wa sahbihi ajma'in.
Dear respected brothers, Assalamu
Alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa
alaykum assalam wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
The topic of my short speech is
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam is
not the founder of Islam.
It is common misunderstanding
among non-Muslims that Islam was started
by the Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam.
However, according the Quran,
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
was not the founder of Islam, but he is
the last and final messenger
of Islam.
For example, Allah mentioned in the
glorious Quran,
in Al-Ahzab, chapter 33, verse 40,
A'udhu billahi min ash-shaytani rajim.
Ma kana Muhammadun aba ahadin min
rijalikum, wa lakin Rasulullah wa khatam
an-nabiyyin, wa kana Allahu bi kulli
shay'in alima. Which means,
"Muhammad is not the father of any of
your men, but he is a message of Allah
and he is the last he is a seal of the
prophets. Allah has knowledge of
everything.
So it's clearly mentioned that he is the
seal of the prophets. He is the seal the
last of the prophets.
In other words, there are prophets
before him.
And 25 prophets are mentioned by name in
the Quran. For example, Adam, Noah,
Ibrahim, Ismail, Isaac,
Musa, Harun,
Dawood, Suleiman, Isa, Muhammad, peace
and blessings of Allah subhana wa ta'ala
upon all of them.
So it is quite clear that
the very
Islam existed since time immemorial,
since the first man Adam alayhis salatu
was salam existed
step
his foot on this earth.
So Islam existed from long time ago
before the prophet of Muhammad salallahu
alayhi wasallam
started to
preaching Islam to mankind.
In conclusion,
Muhammad salallahu alayhi wasallam was
not the
founder of Islam, but he is the last and
final messenger
and the prophet of Islam. Wa akhiru
da'wana alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen.
Allahu
Akbar.
Allahu Allah
Allah